Hey, Vsauce.
Michael here.
Do you remember that Italian researcher I
met in an airplane a couple of months ago?
Well, I had to learn more and so we're gonna
meet tomorrow here in Rome, Italy.
In the meantime, here's some cool things on
the internet that are awesome like you.
Let's begin simply.
Andrew recommended Dodge the Dot, where you
dodge dots.
Step it up a notch with LINK0702 in "Klikwerk,"
a game you win by mousing over and clicking
on stuff.
It's like the website version of Bop It.
If you'd rather just loose and avoid all the
gameplay, try Trollface The Game, let me know
how far you get.
Mightyfigter mentioned Enough plumbers, a
creative game where collecting coins clones
you.
Your clones move like you and can be sacrificed
or positioned in strategic ways.
TheMatia84 sent me Zombotron, which looks
really pretty, but it lacks something important
- cute bunnies and puppies.
Luckily, Ferryhalim has such things.
Mabimanta introduced me to this guy's great
collection of simple little games.
In this one you have to get video footage
of UFOs to sell.
4rvinder reminded me of the useful YouTube
channel "All Time 10s."
These guys release simple videos containing
facts about pretty much anything, organized
into top 10 lists.
Now, speaking of YouTube, let's stick around
and try out YouTube.com/disco.
I briefly mentioned this before.
Just type in a band name and let YouTube do
the work making you a playlist.
Then, beef up your knowledge with YouTube.com/EDU,
a place where educational videos are arranged
by topic, but the coolest thing is the search
bar.
Whatever you search here will only return
related approved educational stuff, so if
I search "Italian," I don't find The Jersey
Shore, I find how to speak Italian.
Get even smarter with Newton, a fun site I
found filled with scientific questions answered
by volunteer scientists.
It's so full of info it can be tough to navigate,
but you'll be surprised what you learn; questions
you never knew you wanted the answers to so
badly.
Now back on YouTube, if you're not sure what
topic to search, YouTube.com/topics covers
the hottest topics of the moment and videos
in that topic.
You can also search, for instance, "what sounds
animals make?"
Now, if you wanna see the hottest individual
videos, YouTube.com/trends is an awesome place.
Using fancy robotic calculations, Trends surfaces
what's rising in popularity often before it
gets too popular.
On Twitter yesterday I shouted out photo2text.com,
which Adam e-mailed to me.
You can upload any picture you want and get
back a bunch of characters that look like
the picture.
Too many DONGs for one lifetime?
Well, get a second with Alterego, a text-based
game where you make decisions that affect
your personality and relationships starting
all the way back to your birth.
Too heavy?
Well alvin37337 recommends Nyan Cat Snake.
Collect the cherries, avoid your own tail.
And as always,
thanks for watching.